yeah you ever find those moments where
you're like you're feeling bad about
something and then you look around and
you're like my life is good I'm such a
nice shut up yeah but it's very normal I
mean you know especially in the Western
culture we are bombarded all the time
with television commercials radio
commercials you're supposed to have all
this stuff want all this stuff you know
all I want now is a little peace of mind
that perhaps the president could give us
but hey that's not so what we did bless
you after he gave his thing and some
people thought well is he big is he like
a supporter or is that a bit of a
sarcasm do you know even in a joke
probably at a prayer meeting you don't
joke about that but I did think that
Schwarzenegger xan sir on on on Twitter
was amazing yeah when he said hey let's
just switch jobs
luckily the I don't know if you saw this
morning our esteemed president has not
let it go and is back to tweeting yes
Arnold Schwarzenegger this one saw that
I saw that you know here is my question
he is our president I want him to do
well I really do right but here it is so
many people are so on edge you feel like
you're not on firm footing all the time
what a weird thing to put out there what
do you think the solution is or if
you've thought about what do you what do
you think might help somebody said this
morning that it is very possible that
the adults in the government now are
starting to make more decisions because
III think that is the thing I don't know
there's so much coming at one time now
I'm sure that that was a great technique
in business where you keep the person
you're making a deal with off their
footing right but you'd probably don't
want to do that for a country right ask
hi except in the million business you
always ask hi I want 500 but I'm gonna
ask for a thousand so I get 500 but
maybe that doesn't work right right
because you also can't make these
promises right where you like
over-promised then kind of just under
deliver but like in business that's the
thing some people decide like well I'm
going to get out
there and I'm gonna sell them the world
and then whatever deal we make deal we
make right but you can't really do that
when you're talking to the American no
not when you're in such a powerful
position and so many people depend on
your thoughtfulness not only in this
country but around the world and let me
just say I sell isolationism probably
doesn't work today since we are so into
woven with everybody in trade you know
and then they talk about I'm gonna bring
back the auto industry well that you
know what that very well might be and
then when all those jobs come back
they're going to be done by robots so
they're still not going to be work for
the wonderful Americans who are
desperate to make it our ends me